Jordan and Jenna break my heart Leo
makes a splash and Kenny kisses everyone
it's time for roses and rose say hi
everybody i'm lauren zima here to recap
episodes four and five of bachelor in
paradise thank you so much for being
here
Wow we've got a lot to cover this show
is so good this season we need to talk
okay so we start off Monday night with
Chris sounding like a complete do you
see Aichi I'm gonna spell it not say it
cuz he doesn't deserve it and again I
say justice for TIA
just5more that ends in E it's not fair
I like you a lot when Chris is telling
her these exploring his options he
doesn't deserve options and Tia deserves
better and I was so frustrated this week
were you frustrated with TIA
and the way that she is allowing Chris
and Colton frankly to treat her I feel
like we're literally in a triangle right
well Chris and Tia and crystal kind of
sort of worked things out I don't know
how I feel about that situation
[Music]
and then crystals should be happy but
within like 30 seconds she's crying an 8
in the morning do not drink every time
someone was crying it what looks like
8:00 in the morning this episode and
when you make moves making moves that's
it it's good advice he's saying if
you're going to date another woman
that's ok but you have to tell the women
that you're dating everyone why is Chris
getting all these women I think it's
just because the men had the upper hand
with the rose Syrena headband I shook my
feelings for Colton but like I'm
remembering all the things that I like
about him Tia has moved on from Chris
and whiplash back to Colton she still
likes him so much
help shallow will be honest we kind of
knew that she did you know and do not
drink every time we wonder if Colton and
Tia are on the same page you guys we are
90% of the time
don't drink every time Colton in Tia
question each other well and I have
never been on the same page or whether
they should be on the show as much as we
thought we were on the same page or
loved in general we have not been on the
same page or themselves fundamentally
don't do it you'll be on the floor in no
time or on the sand so TSS I truly feel
like God is
and will she pass I'm not sure TNN is
crying don't drink every time somebody's
crying in the morning mmm gosh
dark place to come from to start your
day off with a mourning cry you know
that's for when you're alone at night in
bed by yourself not for the full
daylight in front of others anyway
Jacqueline arrives and Colton says
eloquently what am I doing here I'm not
about to go on a date with her while we
still have don't drink every time they
question it crystal and crisp
they're like the two crazies that just
deserve each other in the corner you
know Chris and Krystal what do you guys
think of them as a relationship do you
like it I do I think that they are two
people who needed Redemption stories I'm
not sure if Chris's is gonna come
through didn't headband but Krystal
certainly has redeemed herself and they
have a conversation that is so
horizontal JC can you come reenact it
with me please because I've never seen
two people speak to each other this way
we have to try we have to attempts to
have the Chris and Krystal conversation
because it's as out of whack as they are
is it comfortable for you to talk to me
like this no no
is this my eyes aren't even focusing my
head hurts so this is how Chris and
Chris still have a conversation at 180
degrees or whatever this is and it says
a lot about them Thank You JC we needed
to try it and we don't buy it it was a
weird weird moment everybody crystal
says her quote re me wrong I or a Roth
and Chris sure didn't correct her Roth
IRA 401k everybody get it right learn it
up because they don't teach you in
school okay then we get a conversation
with Tia and crystal on the beach and
it's obviously from the day before
because they're in the same swimsuits
whatever I'm so tired of talking out
this Tia Colton Chris crap and Chris is
such a hypocrite I have to defend Colton
here because he called Colton indecisive
and said that Colton is causing drama
and he's sick of it Chris that's what
you're doing everybody whose side are
you on Chris or Colton and there is a
right answer and it's the one not
wearing a headband okay okay that head
man has the Sun on it but Chris is
bringing me into the darkness so this
also made me sad justice for Tia you're
choosing Colton says I choose you - Tia
like she's up can Pikachu and Pokemon
and no no no yeah just do your own thing
a second Colten or walk down on the
beach then they're together and I think
and we're getting this dramatic
flashback voiceover sequence from
footage from like a day ago I just I'm
dead I'm done with this then luckily
Jordan is around to perk things up he
wears the most amazing outfit to the
rose ceremony you guys Jordan told me he
was going to bring a prototype of a suit
to paradise I didn't know what it was
and now I've seen it come to life it's
whatever the this is cheers to it cheers
- Jordan what did you think of Jordans
outfit did you love it or did you love
it a lot
Jordan and Jenna are just so freaking
cute don't drink every time Jordan and
Jenna are cute he said that one of the
reasons he really likes her is because
she's for coffee my mouth the other day
we were kissing
she's the coffee in my mouth like fresh
I just need a lot of food so sorry if I
look super super
Jubilees says of john quote I don't
think I've ever seen a programmer with
that nice of a body which just made me
wonder how many programmers have you
dated or seemed shirtless zero for me
but hey it's becoming a more needed
profession so you know kids go to school
for coding anyway okay do not drink
every time Kenny was kissing someone hot
dad Kenny out-of-left-field kissing
Jacqueline kissing Annalise kissing
Bibiana by the way I love to be honest
she is just so wonderful and I wish she
could find someone I am 27 and I hope
that's not too old I'm fearing
treacherously towards 30 Jacqueline's
seeming depressed about turning 27 good
god woman
don't put the pressures of culture and
society on yourself I'm gonna put myself
up on a soapbox here for a second and
just say that you get better with age
you become more sure of yourself with
age you know how to be more beautiful
with age because you just learn how you
like to look like age up yes get old
it's congr eight I hope to be just so
old on a porch drinking one day and like
talking about squirrels that's fine with
me and then as long as I have a good
girl friend by my side truly I'll be
good to go
I'll probably still be talking about
this in the show
Oh birthday gift Jenna is kind of
talking to David and I want to give
Jenna some props here because Jenna at
this point is the only woman who is
keeping her options open
we've heard all about all the guys
keeping their options open but drink
every time a woman keeps her options
open yes Jenna hmm even though I don't
love that the person she's keeping her
options open against is George because I
think that Jordan Lee likes her I really
like Jordan Connie look at Mary
Chelsea you don't want it with Jubilee
you don't just John Jordan went over the
edge at the rose ceremony he told some
of the women to shut the F up I'm not
even really sure why it's not really
okay to ever say that to anyone in
general I'm not sure that I think this
is a male-female issue like try not to
tell anybody to shut the F up in anger
it's not good try not to do that
everybody thank you I feel pretty
confident based on the time that we've
had and also people don't like sending
girls home on their birthday and the
rose ceremony Bibiana sad Caroline sad I
think a few other people I'm not sure
let's all go to the lobby to get
ourselves a treat now Tuesday night's
episode yeah
okay we start off strong Leo arrives and
now Kendall is keeping her options open
cheers to Kendall mmm
although Jo is also great so does the
guy like we all threatened me
really yikes um we have this date with
Kendall and Leo and you don't know
what's happening here and you two are
gonna be the main characters of my novel
and I'll tell you about them one of them
is Raul
honest hard-working like chattel there
are some alumni Ben Higgins and a man
the Stanton and and his fiancee Lauren
Burnham have arrived and they're doing
some kind of skit for some characters
that Kendall and Leo are then gonna play
in a photo shoot
I found it unnecessary Ben told me that
they were all flown down for this funny
little skit and I have to be honest I'm
not sure that it was worth the plane
tickets it wasn't that funny to me did
you guys like it did you think the skit
was funny or worthwhile tell me if I
could be wrong I couldn't be wrong maybe
everybody has different humor that's why
it's difficult for comedies to succeed
overseas mistake please connect also I
don't need to see any more apologies
from whether in English or in Spanish I
don't need to see him I'm good oh then
Kendall returns from the date and poor
Jo how bad did you guys feel for grocery
store Jo in this moment the look on his
face I mean he asked Kendall how the
date was and she told him it was great
she told him that she kissed leo and oh
poor Jo who do you think Kendall should
get Leo or Jo because we don't get an
answer here tonight spoiler alert I was
surprised by how serious Kendall seemed
about Leo pretty quickly she said she
saw him as more of a long-term thing I
think that she just means because he
lived physically closer to her in
California jealous in Chicago and this
alumni trip made sense Raven and Adam
who I adore and they are so into each
other come back to CT and Colton and of
course Raven and Tia are very good
friends and so Ravens gonna give her
some advice they're gonna sit down on
this white bench wearing their red and
their blue and they're gonna look like
America and she is going to tell her how
to forge a new country for herself yes
Raven delivering the word saying girl
you deserve better you
Raven said and I quote you should not
settle for anything less than someone
here I don't know if I'm entirely behind
that saying cuz it's like well somebody
can mirror the best parts of you but
then also have a ton of flaws but anyway
Tia really took that to heart and she
did like a total 180 on Colton and then
we got another sad conversation oh I'm
done
drink if you're done I can't handle any
more intense we've got to talk this out
we've got to figure out our two weekend
relationship crap from Tia and Colton
are you done were you frustrated with
the TIA Colton thing let me know
shameless plug I interviewed Annalise
and she told me that everybody there was
pretty frustrated with T and Colton
because they monopolized everything for
the first few weeks of filming mmm I
also want to say Raven said quote and he
can never lose opportunity
I actually didn't think that was an okay
thing to say I want everybody to think
for a second if a man had said something
to that effect even in a joking way
about like doing something about to a
woman not an okay joke I wasn't here for
it Raven it's just how I feel
are you gonna be your girlfriend
yes will you be like but then Tia and
Colton decide to be boyfriend and
girlfriend
what does that mean I thought he already
chose her what does it mean where we add
we're a Pikachu and Charmander and wear
it what a heart so true because it rolls
through time to ankle time Chris Wow
with another banner of a quote quote
Chris boy
I can also say is the only girl that I'm
all-in on right now yeah when you're
all-in it's only on one thing you get a
headband where anyway then Benoit all
those you'll Benoit almost ever been one
come on JC come here we need a couple of
French phrases about Benoit JC can you
give us a few phrases in French about
how the women feel about Benoit which is
that they love him oui oui oui Thank You
JC Christophe
want to go out chat so Benoit likes
blondes and he talks to Krystal first
and he calls her Kendall but I think
that might be just because he wasn't
wearing his glasses and Cristal says I
just have to call this house it was so
weird she says that she wants to lay
down and get comfortable but that if she
gets comfortable her whole butt is gonna
hang out and then she does that and they
black out her but I don't understand the
swimsuit these people are wearing what
swimsuit are you wearing where your butt
isn't hanging out when you're standing
but when you're laying down too much is
hanging out I don't get it I mean once
again it's I mean drink every time they
censor out of but on this show it was
all Jenna all week last week
Jenna and manoir Ghana dates and we are
going to cut - uh just a heartbreaking
moment you guys heart-wrenching
I love Jordan so much and Jordan was
waiting for Jenna and Ben want to come
back from their date and they did have a
pretty good date and Jordan is just
trying to see to her I mean so sincerely
how have I not shown you that I like you
I've been spending all my time with you
he says and I quote sometimes you have
to lose the battle losing a battle to
win the war and that means that Jordan
is the only one not keeping his options
open Jordan or Ryan Gosling it's hard to
tell sometimes these days one of them
wears flashy ER outfits but oh my god
Jordan literally tells her that he is
willing to sit on the sidelines and let
her date other people just because he
wants to show her how much he likes her
and he says and he's all in god Jordan
for Bachelor only of him and Jenna don't
work out I'm just saying you guys I
don't know what there isn't to love
about Jordan at this point he gives the
other guy's good advice he apologizes
when he messes up he wears amazing
outfits he says hilarious crap he's
really smart actually he's super driven
he knows who he is he knows what he
wants and he goes for it I don't tell me
if there's anything you don't like about
Jordan tell me in the comments please I
want to know so that's where we're at
everybody and by the way jenna is
gorgeous and I just love the two of them
together they make beautiful babies so
Jenna
so Jordan I'm not sure that I would say
Jordans having a redemption story
because I liked Jordan on Bachelorette
but who do you guys think is having the
biggest Redemption story on paradise
right now Annalise is an option maybe
crystal Chris I thought but now I'm
taking a turn
let me know because paradise is all
about a second chance and sometimes
remember Nick Mile season we get someone
with a great redemption story we get a
Bachelor out of it the thing thank you
all so much for being here oh I love you
all just as much as I love Jordan and I
love your comments and questions so
please leave them message me anytime on
the instagrams on the Twitter's via an
old-fashioned love letter my
[Music]